ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
says he'll be meeting face-to-face in
the coming hours with united states
secretary of state anthony blinken and
u.s defense secretary lloyd austin
zielinski says he'll use the meeting to
ask the americans for more weaponry to
stop russia's onslaught in ukraine's
east and south this after the president
visited kiev's saint sophia cathedral to
record an easter message on the holiest
day of the orthodox christian calendar
at makeshift prayer venues and churches
around the country ukrainians prayed for
those fighting on the front lines and
for those trapped in places like the
besieged city of
mariopol for more let's cross now to dw
correspondent rebecca ritters in kiev
hey rebecca again top u.s officials are
scheduled to discuss ukraine's request
for more powerful weapons in kiev on
sunday
what's the best ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski could expect from this
meeting
well this is the highest level meeting
from the u.s since the war began i don't
have a list of talking points this is
obviously a very confidential meeting
one thing he can definitely expect is a
guarantee from the americans of
continued support in this conflict and
certainly one the one thing he he wants
can really be summed up in one word
michael and that is weapons from the
very beginning of this conflict
president zelanski has been calling for
support in the way of weapons saying
that if they had the right weaponry they
would already have pushed back the
russians and they would already be
winning this war he's going to be at
pains to underscore and to to really
drive home to the americans that this is
a turning point in the conflict this
regrouping this focus on the east and
south that the russians have now
confirmed that is their plan he said
what happened he believes that what
happens now in this part of the conflict
will determine not just the future of
ukraine and the ukrainian people but
potentially the future of europe and
that is a message he will be driving
home to the americans today rebecca of
course securing those weapons is one
thing uh but one imagines physically
distributing them to the areas where
they're most needed will be
extraordinarily challenging
absolutely as you can imagine big
weapons and also trying to do it under
the cover of darkness this war you know
is one of course where nobody wants the
the the distribution the logistics to
become public you know ukraine does not
want russia to know just how and where
these weapons are going so we're getting
minor bits of information about what's
trickling into the country but in terms
of distribution lines or logistics
routes we just don't have the answers to
those questions you know they're being
transported by rail and road did see
some tanks the other day on a train rail
um you know going through the country
but they're going through civilian areas
michael so obviously a target and nobody
wants the russians to know where they're
going
rebecca stay with us more questions for
you uh in a moment but first we'd like
to give our viewers a look at your
report on ukraine as the nation marks
orthodox easter day you visited one
village northeast of kiev that was under
russian control until a few weeks ago
that community came together to build a
makeshift chapel after russian soldiers
destroyed their church
[Music]
recall and reflection for jesus who
sacrificed all to die on the cross
it's the saddest day in the christian
calendar for the worshipers here in this
village outside kiev their good friday
service in this makeshift chapel has
taken on an even deeper meaning this
year
[Music]
russian soldiers marching on kiev burnt
their 19th century church to the ground
the missile hit the altar of the church
on the eastern side of the building
the damage spread inside the windows
exploded out
it was a direct hit
when the church was burning i thought my
soul was burning
the icon of the prophet elijah the only
thing to survive
it survived under the ruins
under the ashes completely
ukraine is a deeply religious country in
villages like this one the church plays
a central role in the community
these people tell me that while russians
may have destroyed their church they
will never destroy their spirit
the church is our soul we grew up here
when the church was burning right before
our eyes we were very scared
the scariest thing of all was that we
couldn't do anything because we were
under fire
all my childhood was spent here i grew
up three houses down the road so how
should i feel
it's like something is gone from your
life
they vow they'll rebuild their beloved
church in all its former glory once
they're certain the russians won't
return
if they do the priest has a message
straight from the bible
jesus said love one another as i have
loved you
but he also said something else
he who fights by the sword shall die by
the sword
as the service ends they pray for christ
reborn on easter sunday a church rebuilt
and doubtless for a homeland free once
again
[Music]
rebecca today as ukraine endures now the
third month of the russian invasion how
are people spending this rather
extraordinary orthodox easter
well it certainly is an easter like no
other michael we've been here i'm
standing on the forecourt in fact of
michael's church it's one of the biggest
uh cathedrals here in kiev there have
been a lot of people here today
streaming in and out we've been speaking
to some of them asking them whether
they're afraid this year because of the
heightened security the heightened
threats of a potential attack many
people saying that they are concerned
understandably of course but that
they're happy to be able to come out and
celebrate their faith as they do every
year uh we have noticed of course that
the service is different this year
normally there is a midnight mass the
night before so that would have been
last night but that was cancelled
because of martial law and the curfew in
the city or all over the country
so they've changed it so that there are
services all throughout the day to be
able to disperse the crowds they were
warned to stay at home and try and
celebrate there but as you can imagine
many people wanting to come out and and
celebrate their faith which they're
doing and so far it has been safe many
thanks rebecca ritters
like ukraine russia is also a
predominantly orthodox country
president vladimir putin attended an
easter mass early on sunday in moscow's
christ the savior cathedral
the service was led by the head of the
russian orthodox church patriarchy who
said he hoped the conflict in ukraine
would end quickly kirill has strongly
backed the kremlin's war in ukraine his
statements have splintered the worldwide
orthodox church